bonsoir l' affaire tapie provoque des
remous au sein du parti socialiste qui
étaient réunis aujourd'hui en comité
directeur de laurent fabius à pierre
mauroy les responsables du ps ne cachent
pas leur embarras face à la probable
inculpation mercredi prochain du
ministre de la ville certes bernard
tapie n'est pas condamné au ps mais il
n'est pas acquitté non plus au bénéfice
du doute sur place daniels portier les
absents ont toujours tort bernard tapie
sous les feux de l'actualité du comité
directeur du ps l'a vérifié à ses dépens
le ministre de la ville le participe
bien évidemment pas au comité directeur
il n'est pas socialiste mais son nom est
sur toutes les lèvres
bernard tapie doit prendre ses
responsabilités s'il est inculpé
murmure-t-on ici comprendre démissionner
les socialistes et ce au départ des
affaires récentes ont d'ores et déjà
pris leurs distances avec le ministre en
exercice
on va voir comment vont évoluer les
choses dans les jours à venir
mais incontestablement se serait bien
passé de faire un rapide n'a jamais été
ma tasse de thé
on s'est tous souhaitent pas que partie
s'ouvre s'ouvre sourds de cette manière
la route bien sûr un problème dont nous
sommes tous conscients mais je ne crois
pas qu'il faille prononcer des phrases
définitives
aujourd'hui dans un sens ou dans un
autre la justice sera à dire ce qu'elle
souhaite dire et gouvernement pour sa
part le souhaitent s'exprimera en pâture
à dire davantage difficile pour les
socialistes qui prône l'assainissement
de la vie politique et qui ont condamné
une fois de plus très fermement toute
forme d'enrichissement personnel
difficile de ne pas donner l'exemple
d'abord faire le ménage chez soi si
bernard tapie est inculpé il n'aura pas
beaucoup de solidarité à attendre du
côté du parti socialiste un ps qui au
passage n'apprécie pas qu'une nouvelle
affaire risque de compromettre
l'embellie que les socialistes froid
liant dans l'opinion
à la suite de l'effet bérégovoy de son
côté bernard tapie demande à être
traités par la justice comme n'importe
quel citoyen l'homme d'affaires devenu
ministre estime que le secret de
l'instruction n'a pas été respecté dans
son dossier même s'il précise
aujourd'hui que le complot et la
machination dont il a fait état ne vise
pas la justice mais ceux qui l'ont
traîné devant les tribunaux
les syndicats de magistrats ont
néanmoins vivement réagi à ces propos
reportage de nathalie darrigrand je dis
simplement que dans la procédure telle
qu'elle existe aujourd'hui j'ai des
choses qui me surprennent et qui me
montre que je ne suis pas traitées
normalement avec les eau calme la
sérénité le recul
c'est cette petite phrase qui a soulevé
hier l'indignation des juges
l'association professionnelle des
magistrats par le de véritable défi
lancé à la justice tandis que le
syndicat de la magistrature affirme que
le ministre manifeste un mépris absolu
pour le fonctionnement normal de la
justice
il ne peut pas reprocher au juge d'avoir
fomenté comme il semble le dire je ne
sais quel complot ou d'avoir voulu
l'abattre comme homme politique que
l'inculpé se défendent
nous comprenons parfaitement mais qu'un
ministre pour se défendre
viennent ainsi disqualifié
la magistrature en prétendant qu'il
s'agit quasiment de factieux là c'est
extrêmement grave nous ne pouvons pas
l'admettre
devant cette levée de boucliers le
ministre de la ville s'explique dans un
communiqué adressé ce matin à l' agence
france-presse
bernard tapie précise que les termes de
complot et machinations employés ne vise
pas la justice mais s'adresse à georges
tranchant son ancien associé
le député rpr qui l'accusent d'avoir
détourné à son profit
13 millions de francs lors de la vente
de leur société en 85
la plainte de georges tranchant contre x
a permis au juge d'instruction edith
boizette d'ouvrir le dossier toshiba
france de convoquer mercredi prochain le
ministre de la ville et de
vraisemblablement l'inculpent rires et
puis quelques chiffres importants dans
ce contexte selon le baromètre mensuel
ifop journal du dimanche publié demain
le président françois mitterrand
registre en mai une hausse de trois
points avec 29% de satisfaits contre 26
pour cent en avril
les mécontents sont 56 contre 60 selon
cette enquête réalisée du 2 au 12 mai le
premier ministre pierre bérégovoy
enregistre lui une hausse d'un point
passant de 36 à 37 % de satisfaits
contre 19 % de mécontents au lieu de 22
arlette chabot ces chiffres sont là pour
le confirmer
l' affaire tapie est embarrassante pour
tout le monde aujourd'hui
oui effectivement il faut dire d'abord
que au fond le cas tapie a toujours
divisé les socialistes qu'on peut ranger
si vous voulez en trois camps ont
d'abord y aller pour ceux qui misent sur
tapis gagne en le battant et qui
d'ailleurs se voient confortés dans leur
opinion par le résultats qu'il a obtenus
aux élections régionales et ceux qui
sont franchement contre tapis depuis le
début par exemple lionel jospin ou henri
emmanuelli qui n'ont apprécié ni son
style ni son parcours précis personnel
et puis a géré les ambiguë ceux qui
aiment tapis quand il gagne mais qui ne
manque jamais de se démarquer de lui
lorsqu'il est en difficulté ou lorsqu'il
commet une petite bavure
il faut rappeler par exemple que c'est
pierre mauroy qui avait intronisé
monsieur tapie pour les élections
régionales à marseille alors évidemment
le débat avait été relancé entre ces
autres courants du parti socialiste lors
de la formation du gouvernement et
certains dont laurent fabius avait mis
en garde pierre bérégovoy contre le
danger tapie dont le nom était cité dans
un certain nombre de dossiers à l'époque
on pensait notamment
l om et l'on avait répondu à monsieur
fabius et à d'autres que tout avait été
vérifié que des garanties avaient été
prises et de pierre bérégovoy avait
investi monsieur tapie dans son
gouvernement avec l'appui de françois
mitterrand qui lui aussi avait été
impressionné par ses résultats aux
régionales
alors une question encore bernard tapie
clame haut et fort aujourd'hui qu'il ne
démissionnera pas même s'il est inculpé
à votre avis pour at il reste au
gouvernement écoutez ou bien
effectivement il reste et on lui permet
de garder sa ligne de défense qui
consiste à dire et c'est évident qu'un
culte et n'est pas coupable ne veut pas
dire qu'il est coupable et qui sera
condamné ensuite s'il s'agit
effectivement d'une affaire ancienne et
d'une affaire privée ce sont des
affaires personnelles qui n'ont rien à
voir avec l'enrichissement liés par
exemple au financement des partis
politiques mais beaucoup pensent
également qu'il est difficile d'avoir à
la fois le statut de ministre et
d'inculpé que c'est surtout désagréable
pour pierre bérégovoy qui effectivement
connaître un grand succès les sondages
en témoigner qui fait de ce qui se fait
le chantre d'une justice implacable et
de la lutte contre la corruption qui
devrait donc permettre à bernard tapie
de se défendre en dehors du gouvernement
et bien entendu encore une fois c'est au
premier ministre et au président de la
république de décider ce sont eux qui
d'abord jugeront de la gravité du cas
tpiy l'a fait relâche à bourg je vous
rappelle également qu'henri emmanuelli
président l'assemblée nationale sera
demain le grand témoin du 19/20
politique encore les huit élus udf aux
présidences de commissions du conseil
régional de provence alpes côte d'azur
ont démissionné hier soir après les cinq
présidents du groupe nrj sud
cela amènera en début de semaine
prochaine le renouvellement total des
présidences en paca à marseille une
gérard
sur les treize présidents de commissions
qui ont démissionné hier soir cinq
étaient issus de la mouvance énergie sud
de berlin tapis et les huit autres de
l'udf le mouvement qui forment la
majorité relative au conseil régional
les uns et les autres avaient été élus
il ya tout juste une semaine grâce aux
voix du front national qui voulait faire
ainsi la preuve qu'il demeurait maître
du jeu on votera donc le pour désigner
ces treize présidents de commission le
1er juin prochain
mais les mêmes causes risquant de
provoquer les mêmes effets c'est à dire
la réélection des mêmes président avec
les voix du front national
eh bien j sud a décidé de ne pas
présenter de candidats aux commissions
et même de s'abstenir lors des votes ce
qui assurera à la majorité relative
l'élection les amis de jean claude
gaudin en échange le parti socialiste
aurait obtenu que jean claude gaudin
tiennent compte de son opposition de
gauche
la grogne de la france rurale après
l'annonce il ya deux jours de la réforme
de la politique agricole commune cette
nuit des manifestations sporadiques se
sont déroulés dans plusieurs régions
françaises
ici à dijon du fumier a été déposée
devant le domicile du député ps françois
patriat
dans les autres régions quelques bottes
de paille ont été brûlées le plus
souvent devant la préfecture
mais aucun débordement n'a été constatée
les militants de l'est et ceux à estime
que l'agriculture française a été
sacrifié jeudi dernier à bruxelles et
que les responsables européens ont
abandonné les marches aux américains de
son côté le premier ministre pierre
bérégovoy était aujourd'hui à mâcon il a
été directement confronté au
mécontentement du monde agricole
c'est dans un climat très tendu que
pierre bérégovoy le premier ministre a
inauguré la foire de mâcon en fait
d'après midi seul côté bon enfant
l'arrêt traditionnels aux stands de
dégustation dont celui des organisations
viticoles où le premier ministre a eu un
échange verbal assez vif avec le
président des vins de la cour aux
marques jambon en ce moment-même pierre
bérégovoy reçoit à huis clos les
responsables de la fdsea et du cdj à de
saône et loire
la presse a été autorisée à filmer
quelques prises de vue juste avant la
tenue de cette réunion les pierre
bérégovoy dans un premier temps tout est
la salle où se trouvaient les
agriculteurs
on y revenir qu'une fois que les
journalistes est définitivement quitté
l'église à l'étranger le juge anti-mafia
giovanni falcone et est mort ce soir
dans un attentat commis sur une
autoroute près de palerme en sicile nous
venons à l'instant d'apprendre cette
information giovanni falcone était le
principal juge qui s'occupait du dossier
anti mafia
sa voiture a été projetée par une
explosion commises donc au cours d'un
attentat
hors de la chaussée un cratère de deux
mètres s'est ouvert sur la chaussée les
juges falcone qui avait été hospitalisé
à palerme vient donc de décéder selon un
communiqué de l'hôpital de la capitale
sicilienne james baker oslo ton sur la
crise yougoslave le secrétaire d'état
américain qui se dit consterné par
l'attitude des autorités serbes a estimé
qu'il fallait envisager de nouvelles
sanctions économiques et diplomatiques à
l'encontre des autorités serbes
il n'a pas totalement écarté non plus
l'hypothèse d'une action militaire
pascal verneau le coup de semonce
américain à la serbie visage grave
james baker énumère les mesures de
rétorsion américaine fermeture de deux
consulats yougoslave aux états unis
rupture des contrats militaires avec
l'armée fédérale
et il ajoute si toutes les actions
politiques économiques menées par le
monde civilisé échoue dans ce cas
seulement il faudrait envisager une
action militaire
réponse prudente de douglas hurd son
homologue anglais oui aux pressions mais
attention au risque d'embourbement
allusion la mission périlleuse des
casques bleus en croatie dont les
efforts se heurte à l'obstruction de
l'armée cerveau fédéral est mise en
garde il y à quelques heures du conseil
de sécurité des nations unies qui
pourrait décréter des sanctions
économiques contre le gouvernement de
belgrade
l'homme fort du régime slobodan
milosevic qui a construit toute sa
stratégie sur la manière d'éviter une
internationalisation du conflit et donc
de plus en plus isolé
dans la presse américaine extrêmement
critique quant aux atermoiements de
l'europe
les éditorialistes n'hésite pas à parler
du saddam hussein serbe même voilé la
déclaration baker est une menace sa part
la communauté européenne a franchi
aujourd'hui un pas de plus dans
l'instauration d'un embargo commercial
contre la serbie les ministres des 12
réunis à lisbonne ont chargé leurs
experts d'opérer mardi prochain un choix
dans la liste des sanctions présentées
par la commission européenne
et puis toujours à lisbonne où sont
réunis près de 60 pays pour examiner les
moyens de venir en aide aux républiques
de l'ex urss
le premier effet de surprise de cette
réunion est venue d'un accord entre les
etats-unis la russie l'ukraine le
kazakhstan et le bélarus ils ont signé
en effet en soirée un protocole de mise
en oeuvre de l'accord start sur le
désarmement nucléaire à lisbonne un
reportage de notre envoyé spécial jean
maridor après huit mois de tractations
les etats-unis et les pays de l'ex urss
ont donc signé à lisbonne le traité
start qui prévoit la réduction de
l'arsenal nucléaire de longue portée de
part et d'autre ces armes stratégiques
de l'ancienne armée rouge sont basés
aujourd'hui à quatre endroits en russie
en ukraine au bélarus et au kazakhstan
et c'est donc avec ces pays là héritier
de l'ex urss de gorbatchev qu'il a fallu
tout renégocier
après tout c'est gorbatchev qui avait
signé le traité start avec george bush
en juillet 91
aux termes de l'accord d'aujourd'hui
c'est en russie et là seulement que
toutes ses armes nucléaires seront
rassemblés les etats-unis ont fait là un
beau coup en réussissant deux choses
d'abord éviter la dissémination toujours
possible surtout dans des états neufs et
peu sûr et on obtenait ensuite le
retrait de partout du nucléaire qui
reste concentrée dans la seule russie
c'est aussi un beau coup médiatique des
américains ici à lisbonne après tout
cette conférence et celle de l'aide aux
républiques de l'ex urss
elles ont besoin d'environ 260 milliards
de francs ce n'est pas rien pour éviter
le naufrage dont plus de la moitié pour
la seule russie
or qui les aident ces pays et bien aux
trois quarts la communauté économique
européenne pour l'aide humanitaire et
alimentaire et aux deux tiers toujours
la communauté
pour les crédits à l'exportation et
l'assistance technique les états unis
qui dit-on ici font de grands discours
et beaucoup de promesses ne participe
vous l'avez vu qu'à peine à hauteur de
10% et les accords start signé
aujourd'hui de façon hâtive et
spectaculaires sont peut-être fait aussi
pour masquer ses insuffisances
aux etats unis le deuxième procès de la
sphère rodney king se tiendra à
l'automne à los angeles l'un des quatre
policiers blancs qui avaient brutalement
frappée l'automobiliste noir sera rejugé
pour violence sous le couvert de son
autorité j'en équipements le mois
dernier avait provoqué des émeutes dont
le bilan définitif s'élève à 59 morts
dédié aurillac
laurence powell n'échappera pas à un
nouveau procès trois semaines après son
acquittement ce policier blanc
retournera donc devant les juges
il est accusé d'avoir roué de coups un
automobiliste noir
par crainte de nouvelles émeutes comme
celles qui ont éclaté début mai son
procès a finalement été renvoyé à los
angeles
il devait initialement se dérouler à
simi valley une localité à majorité
blanche et où vivent de nombreux
responsables des forces de l'ordre
une décision qui aurait été sans doute
perçue par la population noire comme une
nouvelle provocation
au dernier bilan les violences de début
mai déclenchée par la remise en liberté
de laurence powell et de ses trois
collègues auraient causé la mort de 59
personnes
par ailleurs à la suite des destructions
matérielles plus de trente mille
personnes auraient perdu leur emploi
enfin le manque à gagner dans le domaine
touristique s'élèverait à plus de 1
milliard de dollars
en france une centaine de mineurs de fer
bloquent depuis hier le centre ville de
metz ils protestent contre la fermeture
de la mine de mary en meurthe et moselle
dont les activités cesseront le 30 juin
prochain
paralysie à metz donc reportage sur
place de joël barre si pour tout le
week-end les mineurs de fer ont décidé
de maintenir leur quartier général dans
le centre ville de metz malgré son lot
de désagréments ultime décision ce matin
après des heures de négociations à la
préfecture
où le préfet m'a dit est saine a tenté
de jouer les médiateurs entre la
direction générale de leur mine et la
cgt à 1h30 ce matin l'ensemble des
parties à quitter la salle avec quelques
avancées la petite a on revient aux
mesures d'accompagnement antérieures
petit b le 30 juin n'est plus une date
butoir les salariés pourront encore
chercher un emploi tout en étant payé
par lots remis ce matin réunion avec la
base à 10 heures
apparemment les salariés ne veulent pas
céder vous êtes vous resté un oui non
des dents dans un mois de deux ordres
est ce assez partagé par une partie des
démineurs ou pas de grille je pense que
les avancées d'hier soir ça vous suffit
pas mais non puisque pour les gens qui
auront en dessous de 25 ans domine et
c'est la majorité des gens il n'y a
aucune avancée
c'est à dire que le gars qui va se
retrouver avec 24 en 2018 en mines ou 15
ans domine le problème n'est pas réglé
c'est à dire qu'il va se retrouver sur
la paille à l'unanimité moins trois
voire les mineurs ont donc décidé de
rester sur metz société publication
aujourd'hui du décret d'application de
la nouvelle loi sur la lutte contre les
chèques sans provision cette loi qui
entrera en vigueur le 1er juin
elle devrait sensiblement favoriser le
sort de toutes les victimes des mauvais
payeurs des précisions avec claude
lienhard depuis un peu plus d'un an la
banque de france établi un fichier
national sur informatique des chèques
volés ou perdus avec la nouvelle loi les
commerçants auront accès à ce fichier
qui leur signale également le nom des
personnes interdites de chéquier les
listes sont consultables par un lecteur
similaire à celui utilisé pour les
cartes bancaires ou par minitel la loi
qui entre en vigueur le 1er juin
renforce également la lutte contre les
chèques sans provision il y en a 5
millions par an l'émetteur d'un chèque
en bois sera interdit de chéquier et
devra restituer tous ces formulaires à
sa banque ou à ses banques
de toute façon le fichier national sera
là pour signaler les mauvais payeurs
ces derniers ne recouvreront leur droit
de faire des chèques qu'après avoir payé
leur dette
il y aura des amendes en cas de récidive
interpellation insolite aujourd'hui à
besançon un autocar en provenance du
maroc et à destination de la
tchécoslovaquie a été intercepté avec à
son bord près d'un millier d'animaux
interdits à la commercialisation par les
conventions internationales ces
touristes tchèques qu'ils encourent des
peines de prison circuler au milieu de
lézards de scorpions et autres serpents
à besançon raul advocat un autocar
tchécoslovaque avec une trentaine de
touristes quoi de plus banal mais les
douaniers de besançon sont surpris
d'entendre des petits bruits bizarres
dans les bagages et sous les sièges
quelques heures plus tard la direction
régionale des douanes est une nurserie
pour un millier d'animaux du maroc
lézards serpents écureuils tortueuses et
insectes de l'araignée au scorpion un
point commun pour la plupart ils sont
protégés par la convention de washington
exportations interdite
quelles sont les chances de survie des
animaux saisis les chances de survie
sont malheureusement relativement faible
parce que nous avons eu affaire là un
transit qui s'est passé sur de
nombreuses journées en quarts dans des
conditions malheureusement très pénible
pour les animaux puisqu'il était en
sachet empilées
auprès de bagages le car était bondée de
bagages et lorsque nous avons sorti
effectivement nous avons rencontré
animaux dre état d'hygiène assez
lamentable loin de leur ca rame attal
ces animaux représentent un joli pactole
au marché noir
environ 250 mille francs ils ont été
confiés aux autres de la citadelle de
besançon
les trafiquants des amateurs semble-t-il
il tentait de revendre les animaux dans
les différentes villes traversées pour
rentrer chez eux
il risque un an de prison ferme et de
fortes amendes
serge blanco terminera sa carrière de
joueur de rugby par une apothéose blanco
disputera en effet la finale du
championnat de france le 6 juin prochain
au parc des princes finale pour laquelle
il s'est qualifié cet après midi avec
son club de biarritz aux dépens de
grenoble jean philippe qui il reste une
minute à jouer et biarritz en blanc et
rouge mène d'un point devant grenoble
sur cette mêlée à bâle partir à hawaii
états qui passe le drop 13 à 9 cecchini
pour la première fois
serge blanco va disputer à paris la
finale du championnat de france
une victoire logique dans la tonicité
des avants de biarritz a parfaitement
animé la puissante que c'est de grenoble
il ne sert à rien pour les basques le
premier dès le début de la rencontre la
défense grenobloise fébrile a relâché le
ballon
6 à 0 car ce premier essai est
transformé
arrieta toujours en première mi-temps
direct va superbement combiné sur cette
touche le pack travail en force et c'est
le pilier mandela qui va conclure juste
à côté du poteau de points à cet instant
biarritz mène 10 3 malgré les points
inscrits au pied par vélo ici sa vie des
55 m biarritz va magnifiquement résisté
au retour des grenoblois ici puis 19
mais grenoble va rater quatre occasions
nettes de prendre la tête
serge blanco n'avait jamais eu le
plaisir de venir à paris disputé la
finale son club biarritz n'était pas
revenue qu'en 1939 pour le plaisir
blanco sera le 6 juin au parc des
princes
capitaine d'une équipe exemplaire au jeu
offensif et spectaculaire
serge a tenté et réussi cet après midi
des gestes techniques exceptionnelles le
monde de la musique est en deuil
chanteur compositeur argentin atahualpa
yupanqui est mort cette nuit y anime à
l'âge de 83 ans à ce kit ariste virtuose
artisan du renouveau de la musique
traditionnelles latino américaine avait
chanté dans le monde entier la
maintiennent des plaines et des tirades
de son pays il affirmé
qu'un poète n'avait pas de biographie
car sa vie était tout entière dans son
livre
des photos rock pour terminer ce journal
c'est l'une des plus belles expositions
à ce moment à paris la première
rétrospective d'annie leibovitz
depuis 20 ans elle a essentiellement
photographier des stars de la musique
qu'elle travaillait surtout pour le
magazine rolling stone en reportage de
tristan fleurs et de philippe basquin
est ok john lennon quelques heures avant
son assassinat par la force des choses
ce cliché l'un des plus célèbres d'annie
leibowitz depuis le début des années 70
elle était reconnue pour avoir su
parfaitement capturer l'esprit de son
époque
sur cette photo de paul cancer et de
grace slick du jefferson airplane
tout y est le lit symbole de libération
sexuelle la fumée du juin et le contact
corporel avec l'enfant du couple
annie leibowitz multiplie les
couvertures des magazines et devient la
photographe du rock
mick jagger souhaitait tout montrer de
l'envers du décor d'une tournée des
rolling stones qui s'ensuivra un modèle
de reportages contraste entre les
lumières de la scène et les nuits de
défonce dans les suites des hôtels de
luxe américain peu à peu le travail dany
face à la couleur et les photos
deviennent de plus en plus sophistiqués
ce sont les années 80 et la spontanéité
n'est plus qu'un souvenir
l'humour pointe malgré tout vous pitbull
berck dans un bain de lait christo
emballe et à son tour faute aux gags
résultat d'une vraie complicité entre
annie les mobiles et ses modèles
l'expo annie leibowitz se tient au
palais de tokyo à paris jusqu'au 27
juillet
pour l'instant météo rock et orageuses
de michel touré prochain rendez-vous
d'information soir 3 à 22h40 je vous
souhaite d'ici là un excellent début de
soirée merci
e